en el último vídeo realizamos una
exploración visual de la relación que
existe entre las sesiones a las que
asisto y el costo mensual de acuerdo a
los distintos planes así que aquí con
esta recta en azul visualizamos el plan
de prueba mientras que con esta recta
punteada en naranja visualizamos el plan
básico y cumple representa
intuitivamente lo que hemos entendido
acerca de los dos planes para el plan de
prueba no necesitas pagar nada en un
principio pero cada que tomas una sesión
que te mueves uno a la derecha tienes
que pagar 12 dólares te mueves 12 hacia
arriba tomas otra sesión te mueves 12
hacia arriba otra sesión más te mueves
12 hacia arriba para el plan básico si
hay que dar un pago inicial de 20
dólares pero la recta es menos inclinada
tienes que pagar menos por cada sesión
en este plan al tomar una sesión sólo
tienes que agregar 8 dólares al costo
mensual tomas otra sesión sólo tienes
que agregar 8 dólares así que
recta naranja empieza más arriba pero
tiene una menor inclinación y es por eso
que las rectas claramente se intersectan
y se intersectan las rectas intersectan
aquí y la pregunta que ahora te hago es
que significa cuál es el significado de
este punto de intersección bien pensemos
un momento sobre esto cuál es el costo
para cada plan si solo asisto a una
sesión vemos aquí que para el plan de
prueba nos va a costar 12 dólares
mientras que para el plan básico si sólo
existe una sesión nos va a costar 28
dólares y no necesitas recurrir a las
tablas que construimos lo puedes
apreciar aquí visualmente para una
sesión el plan de prueba está abajo del
plan básico si vas a dos sesiones el
plan de prueba aún es más barato que el
plan básico aquí ves que estos dos
puntos están más cerca la diferencia
entre estos costos es menor para tres
sesiones aún el costo del plan básico es
mayor que el plan de prueba y así vemos
que los costos se van acercando cada vez
más hasta llegar a este punto de aquí
es básicamente el número de sesiones y
aquí de acuerdo a la gráfica son cinco
sesiones las cuales son el número de
sesiones donde el costo del plan básico
y el plan de prueba es el mismo y esto
lo vamos a verificar en un momento y
aparentemente el costo es de 60 dólares
lo cual también estamos por verificar y
si vamos más allá de ese punto el costo
del plan básico es menor que el costo
del plan de prueba aquí vemos que si
tomamos 6 sesiones el plan básico nos
sale más barato que el plan de prueba
pero como le hacemos para calcular cuál
es de hecho este punto cuántas sesiones
y cuál es el costo en dólares lo
acabamos de determinar a ojo y eso es
una gran ventaja de este apoyo gráfico
pero qué tal si quiero precisar el
número de sesiones y el costo en dólares
quizás son 5.1 sesiones y 62 dólares
como obtenemos el valor preciso bueno
una manera de hacer esto es determinar
el número de sesiones para las cuales no
importa el plan que elijas el costo es
el mismo sabe
que si elegimos el plan básico el costo
será 20 + 20 + 820 + 8 por s 20 + 8 s y
si elegimos el plan de prueba el costo
será 12 por s 12s y queremos encontrar
el valor de s donde este valor es igual
a este valor es ese valor desconocido
del número de sesiones para las cuales
el costo mensual es igual sin importar
el plan que tú elijas nos interesa
entonces el valor de s donde 12 s es
igual a 20 + 8 s así es que hemos
establecido una ecuación con una
incógnita que deberemos de poder
resolver
veamos cómo lo vamos a hacer cuál es la
idea general cuando estamos tratando de
resolver una ecuación y hay varias
opciones para esto y es lo bonito del
álgebra que tienes distintos caminos
para mí lo primero que hay que hacer es
despejar las
ese es hay que agrupar las heces de un
lado y yo lo que va a hacer es voy a
despejar las heces del lado derecho aquí
tenemos 12 ese positivo y de aquí
tenemos un 20 y eso facilita las cosas
cómo le hacemos entonces para
deshacernos de este 8 es la manera más
fácil de lograr esto es restar 8 s del
lado izquierdo restamos entonces 8 s del
lado izquierdo pero si hacemos eso
entonces está igualdad ya no se va a
sostener teníamos una igualdad pero
cuando restamos 8 s al lado izquierdo
éste ya no es igual al lado derecho
entonces para mantener la igualdad para
mantener la ecuación restamos 8 s del
lado derecho también que nos queda
entonces del lado izquierdo estos
términos se cancelan y nos queda
únicamente 20 nos queda únicamente 20
déjame ponerlo con el mismo color
nos queda 20 y del lado derecho que nos
queda del lado derecho tenemos 12 ese y
estamos restando le 8 s 12 ese menos 8
ese nos queda 4
4s y ahora ya estamos cerca necesitamos
dejar la s sola del lado derecho que
puedo hacer en esta ecuación para tener
solo s del lado derecho la manera más
fácil de hacer esto es dividir ambos
lados entre 4
así es que dividimos a ambos lados entre
4 no puedo hacerlo tan sólo de un lado y
cuando divido ambos lados entre 4 que es
lo que resulta para ese del lado derecho
4 s dividido entre 4 se simplifican los
4 y me queda tan sólo ese y del lado
izquierdo del lado izquierdo tenemos 20
entre 4 y 20 entre cuatro es igual a 5
lo habíamos estimado a ojo de la gráfica
pero ahora hemos verificado que el costo
para cinco sesiones es igual para ambos
planes pero cuál es ese costo para
cualquier plan en este caso podemos ir a
cualquier plan pues el costo es el mismo
si tomamos entonces el plan de prueba si
tomamos el plan de prueba y queremos
calcular el costo para cinco sesiones
ese costo va a ser igual
a 12 por 5 así es que el costo va a ser
igual a 12 por 5 12 por 5 que es igual
es igual a 60 dólares ahora te pregunto
necesitamos probar también cuál es el
costo para cinco sesiones en esta
ecuación cuál es el costo de cinco
sesiones para el plan básico bien no lo
necesitamos pues la razón por la cual lo
obtuvimos cinco sesiones puede
considerar que este es el número de
sesiones para el cual el plan básico
tiene exactamente el mismo costo que el
plan de prueba pero para que no te quede
la duda te invito a que sustituya el
valor de 5 en esta ecuación vas a
obtener 20 más 8 por 5 20 más 40 es
igual a 60 dólares así que para
cualquier plan con cinco sesiones el
costo total va a ser de 60 dólares y
entonces si agregas sesiones a partir de
ahí si agregas más sesiones debido a que
la recta del plan de prueba es más
inclinada cada incremento de sesión te
va a costar más caro aquí puedes ver que
el plan de prueba es cada vez más
entonces volviendo a la pregunta de cuál
de estos planes es más conveniente para
mí de repente encontramos una respuesta
muy interesante si pretendo asistir en
promedio menos de cinco sesiones menos
de cinco sesiones al mes entonces lo más
conveniente para mí es el plan de prueba
si pretendo asistir más de cinco
sesiones al mes entonces el plan básico
es más barato si pretendo asistir
exactamente cinco sesiones al mes
entonces no importa cuál es el plan que
utilizo